If you've been following the hype
on all the talk about the differences
between introverts and extroverts,
you've probably already heard that
introverts typically prefer quiet environments,
whereas extroverts often enjoy exploring new places
and meeting new people.
While this is true,
it only remains half truthful
for those who identify
as highly sensitive extroverts
*rewiring tape sound*
Wait, what?
But aren't introverts
usually the highly sensitive ones?
Turns out introverts aren't
the only ones who face misconceptions.
So if introverts and extroverts
can both be highly sensitive individuals,
are introverts still the ones
more likely to identify as HSPs?
Well, according to Dr. Elaine Aron,
author of "The Highly Sensitive Person":
70% of the HSP population
identify as introverts,
which leaves 30 percent
who are sensitive extroverts
Although the percentage of HSP introverts
definitely outweigh HSP extroverts,
This only creates space
for harmful labels and stereotypes,
Such as the belief that
extroverts only act or behave
in a particular manner.
Whether someone is an introvert or extrovert,
the following four criteria
is used to determine high sensitivity:
1, Depth of processing
2, Overstimulation
3, Emotional responsiveness and empathy
4, Sensitive to subtleties
If you want to learn more about
how highly sensitive people function,
check out this video after here.
Although Susan Cain
is known to be the catalyst
for the big introvert movement,
Elaine Aron's research on HSPs
disproves her broad generalizations
of what being introverted and extroverted means.
In Cain's book "Quiet"
she describes extroverts as
one who is sociable, gregarious,
excitable, dominant, light-hearted,
bold and comfortable in the spotlight.
She then describes introverts
as being deep thinkers,
preferring to process slowly,
sensitive to stimuli,
emotionally reactive,
meeting time alone and so forth.
Which, according to Aron are all qualities
of a highly sensitive person.
But as an HSP extrovert,
she identified with all of those traits.
And if that wasn't contradicting enough,
her husband, a non-HSP introvert
wasn't able to fully identify
with these listed qualities.
Confused? We were too.
So, then what differentiates
HSP introverts and extroverts
from non-HSP introverts and extroverts?
According to Aron's research,
she discovered that those who score highly
on the MBTI tests
with NF or NT temperaments
usually identify as highly sensitive people.
Meanwhile, fewer HSPs leaned more
towards the SF and ST temperaments.
F and T stand for feeling and thinking,
but it's the differences
between N and S
that contributes to high sensitivity.
The N stands for intuiting
while the S stands for sensing.
Intuitive HSP people are more interested
in exploring theories and ideas
whereas sensing non-HSP individuals
care more about what's real
rather than abstraction.
Hence, they enjoy the stimulation
the physical world provides
because it's their playground
and where they make meaning.
Meanwhile intuitive folks don't mind
escaping and living in their imaginations.
So in conclusion, both introverted
and extroverted HSPs
enjoy alone time, less stimulating environments
and prefer deep discussions over small talk.
But what differentiates them is that
HSP extroverts prefer to
talk about their thoughts and feelings out loud
rather than writing about them
And if they spend
too much time in their heads,
they'll start to grow restless
and need to explore
the outside world for rejuvenation.